everywhere there's danger
nowhere's more dangerous in Motorsport
and yet they keep coming to compete I'm
not forced to be here I want to be here
it's an obvious risk risks Riders have
been taken for 116 years at the Isle of
Man TT with the course death toll
reaching 266 after six more fatalities
in 2022 but no one here especially not
the Island's fastest ever racer was to
contemplate Banning the world's oldest
motorcycle race after the tranches of
last year did you have any trepidation
about coming back this year to compete
not at all no I mean a lot of people
think we're just crazy are idiots you
take your brain out put your helmet on
it's very very much the opposite effect
so you've really got to use your brain
and you've got to take the risk when you
once take the risk or if it's necessary
but life is short as it is you know I
would rather
go away doing something like this and I
would crossing the road and getting run
over by a bus
but this is where no one wants to end up
a rider has been injured on the first
morning of racing
and they arrive at hospital as we're
meeting the events medical Chief the
circuit's 37 miles long approximately uh
we're about 20 miles from some of the
patients who are having the helicopters
uh is absolutely essential it gets the
doctor and the paramedic there literally
within minutes so a vital piece of our
response speeds can reach 200 miles an
hour
in racing compared to jumping out of a
plane without a parachute padding on
Lamppost offers little protection
it's around here a father and son Roger
and Bradley stopped and crashed in a
sidecar race and died last year it's
racing around these residential streets
that makes the Isle of Man TT so
thrilling so compelling yet so dangerous
it's so perilous that world championship
status was lost in 1932. yet new safety
measures organized and insists should
reduce the risk of more Riders dying
here it is inherently dangerous or um
we're racing in high performance
motorcycles on a closed Public Road and
those dangers are are obvious
um
there is a kind of constant battle to to
manage the um the the those risks that
are avoidable that sit around this to
try and make it as safe as possible to
win you must risk dying without the
rewards of other sports grief goes with
the glory Rob Harris Sky News on the
Isle of Man
foreign